about 10 or 15 years ago a successful
Hollywood producer named Aaron rouso sat
for an interview that uh nobody really
talks about anymore rouso was uh bet
Midler's manager he worked on the film
Trading Places and in this interview
Russo goes into some detail about a
conversation he had with one of the
members of the Rockefeller family
specifically Russo claims that the the
Rockefeller foundation and the US
government spent a lot of money funding
the feminist movement for reasons that
are not remotely related to equal rights
or empower ing women watch he were
talking and he started laughing he said
Aon what do you think women's Liberation
was
about and uh I said I I pretty
conventional thinking about it at that
point I said I think that women having
the right to work getting equal pay with
men just like they won the right to vote
you know and he start to laugh he said
you're an idiot and I said why am I an
idiot he said you want let me tell you
what that was about we the Rockefellers
funded that we funded women's lib you
know and we're the ones who got all over
the newspapers and television the
Rockefeller
Foundation he says and you want to know
why he say there were two primary
reasons and they were one reason was we
couldn't tax half the population before
women's live and the second reason was
now we get the kids in school at an
early age we can indoctrinate the kids
how to think which it breaks up their
family the the kids start looking at the
state as the family as the school as the
officials as the family not as the
parents teaching
them now watching that footage there are
reasons to be skeptical even though
pretty much every conspiracy theory from
the past decade has been proven correct
it's still hard to say whether rouso is
a credible source of information but if
Aaron Russo is a fraud he has one thing
that most frauds don't have which is
corroboration this corroboration comes
in the form of a document that was
drafted uh not by some online troll or
by a dastardly Maga Republican or
anything like that Instead This document
was written by a vice president at one
of the most powerful left-wing activist
groups in the country uh an organization
you've probably heard of called planed
Parenthood and every year for decades
planed Parenthood has received hundreds
of millions of dollars of taxpayer
funding in terms of political impact
they are maybe the single most
influential nonprofit in the United
States and I use the term nonprofit very
Loosely just like Planned Parenthood
does about five decades ago in
1969 planed Hood produced a step-by-step
road map for depopulating the United
States and this document is called the
jaff memo after the man who drafted it
Frederick jaff who is also the founder
of The pro-abortion gutmacher Institute
he wrote the document in response to a
letter from Bernard burlson who was the
head of the population Council and
burlson wanted a summary of expert
opinions on how to make sure that we
have fewer people in this country that's
what the jaff Momo supposed to outline
kind of a road map for accomplishing
that Jeff's memo makes clear that the
feminist movement is a core component of
a much broader depopulation agenda and
that agenda has been achieved for the
most part Point by point it has become
reality just like they drew it up you go
back to 1969 and read this memo and you
will see uh from that from that vantage
point a look into the
future if you want evidence that pretty
much every problem facing Americans
today was not just predictable but
planned then this memo is very
interesting reading to say the least and
if you want to know where the
depopulation agenda is heading in the
future then it's vitally important that
you understand every word of the
document so I'm going to go through the
document this is a memo that I've
alluded to at various points uh on this
show over the years we never spent much
time analyzing it in detail but today we
will that's because it is maybe the
single most important document that most
people have never heard of the jaff memo
begins with this statement quote
continued US population growth will
inevitably cause a deterioration in the
quality of life of this and future
Generations the document adds that many
experts believe that quote explicit US
policy to encourage or compel smaller
family size in the US is
necessary now what policy proposals
might achieve this goal of depopulating
the planet well here's the First Column
of a chart included at the end of the
jaff memo it says quote restructure
family postpone or avoid marriage alter
image of Ideal family size compulsory
education of children encourage
increased
homosexuality educate for family
limitation fertility control agents in
the water supply encourage women to
work okay let's go through these one by
one restructure family postpone or avoid
marriage well they accomplished that one
obviously in the 1960s the median age of
first marriage for men was 23 and for
women it was 20 now the median age for
men at their first wedding is over 30
and for women it's 29 this has been a
slow and steady climb and it's still
increasing and you have to keep in mind
of course that for women fertility
starts to decline rapidly at the age of
30 and now it is right at that moment
right when fertility is declining right
when it hits it it you know it hits uh
the precipice and starts to decline that
women are now getting married
now of course there have always been
women who marry later in life and
there's nothing wrong with that on an
individual level but as a general
societal strategy it is a recipe for
Decline and eventually
disaster and this is a recipe that was
as it turns out quite intentionally
concocted now let's take the next part
of the memo alter image of Ideal family
size and that happened very quickly the
Jeff memo was written in 1969 just a
couple of years later Pew reports that
people suddenly wanted much smaller
amilies quote in 1971 there was a shift
in attitudes As Americans ideal family
switched from four kids to two kids so
just as contraception is being legalized
suddenly everybody wants fewer kids
another goal of the antihuman forces was
achieved the Jeff memo continues by
calling on policy makers to encourage
increased
homosexuality so 1969 they said this is
what we're going to
do now they appear to be doing it and if
you point out that they're doing it of
course say that's not what we're
doing but in black and white plan parent
is saying two things at once first that
homosexuality can be encouraged it's not
a naturally occur occurring phenomenon
at least not in their opinion if it can
be
encouraged and then plan paranoid is
admitting that the goal of encouraging
increased homosexuality is not about
equal rights it's about curbing the
human
population in various corners of
left-wing media you'll find tcid
admission that this is the reason
they're so adamant about promoting
homosexuality the huan post for example
published an article in 2017 entitled
homosexuality is population control why
gays and lesbians are essential to the
balance of nature the article stated
that quote even without a causal link
established between homosexuality and
population management the obvious
reduction in population growth
attributable to homosexuality by itself
indubitably Works to preserve the
species now if you've ever wondered why
it's always the case that the climate
nut jobs are in complete agreement with
the lgbtq club if you've been curious
what you know environmental Marxism has
in common with gay marriage well there's
your answer the left views the climate
agenda and the gay agenda as two
components of a larger plan which is
about among other things depopulating
the planet the holidays are rapidly
approaching but we can find peace and
calm in the craziness of the season with
hallow the number one Christian Prayer
app in the world immerse yourself in
Christmas and Advent prayers meditations
and peaceful Christmas music hallow also
off offers an extensive library of Bible
reading plans accompanied by insightful
Reflections and Audi guided meditations
whether you're a seasoned Bible reader
or just starting your journey H provides
a platform for you to engage with
scripture like never before a great
place to start is with father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year in which he
offers brief daily readings and
Reflections the hall app also helps you
connect with a community of like-minded
individuals sharing experiences insights
and encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth this Christmas join
Hallow's Christmas prayer challenge
Advent with CS Lewis for the 25 days
leading up to Christmas you can focus on
the real reason for the season with
prayer meditation and Christmas music on
hallow download the app for free at
hall.com
Walsh for three months free that's
Walsh the First Column of this memo ends
with these two action items fertility
control agents and the water supply
encourage women to
work now it goes without saying that
they have encouraged women to work there
are more women in the workforce than
ever before there are also more women
taking ssris and divorcing their
husbands so you know mission
accomplished but the other bullet point
needs some more explanation fertility
control agents in the water
supply I mean what could that possible I
mean outside of chemical spills from
train derailments where have we seen
that well we have seen it um again
pretty much no one talks about it but
it's true here's an article from the
daily mail from October 2020 quote birth
control hormone is making its way into
streams and hindering fish's ability to
reproduce the article notes that quote
up to 90% of birth control is
unmetabolized and flushed down the
toilet the piece continues a 2015 study
from Washington State University found a
link between synthetic estrogen and the
growing decline in sperm counts which
have plummeted up to 38% in a decade
now this synthetic estrogen can have
effects on humans uh even in in very
limited concentrations Frederick Von
solul a biology professor at the
University of Missouri told the National
Catholic register that the fake estrogen
quote can cause effects in human tissue
at concentrations in blood below one
part per trillion so this is an
extremely potent
drug is that why sperm counts and men
are
plummeting is that way birth R rates are
dropping no one's been able to offer an
explanation for what happening to sperm
counts but it's clearly a major problem
watch if you look at the sperm
concentrations when we last looked at
them which was samples collected in 2011
the sperm concentration in Western
countries was 47 million per milliliter
down from 99 million per milliliter 39
years earlier so that's a decline of
more than 1% per year and it would
predict between 2011 and now which is 10
years that we would be now below 40
million per
milliliter and that's an important
number because below 40 it becomes
increasingly difficult for couples to
become pregnant and how low it's going
to go before we wake up and say we have
to stop this I don't know how long
that's going to take but it's
urgent this is another one of those
things that um it's a catastrophic like
world changing potentially civilization
ending problem that almost nobody talks
about and does this crisis have anything
to do with the chemicals we're putting
in the water supply and in
Pharmaceuticals if so it would be yet
another bullet point achieved by Planned
Parenthood in their agenda so let's go
through the rest of it uh It also says
modify tax policies substantial marriage
tax tax married more than single reduce
eliminate paid maternity leave or
benefits now for most coupl couples we
don't have any kind of tax penalty for
marriage in this country at least not
officially not yet um that's one element
of the jaff Melo that remains
unfulfilled but maternity to leave and
benefits are definitely on the decline
CNBC reports that quote in 20122
organizations offering employees paid
maternity leave dropped to 35% from 53%
in 2020 currently there isn't a federal
paid Lea program and only 11 states plus
the District of Columbia offer the
benefit if you go down the list uh back
to the jaff memo you'll find these two
words chronic depression that's under
the column heading of economic deterrent
incentives for depopulating the planet
so they want to make sure that as many
people are as depressed as possible and
then because they're depressed they
won't want to start a family now this is
something that you never hear anyone say
out loud we're supposed to pretend that
everyone's trying to prevent chronic
depression that the ssris are making
everything better Etc but at least for
plant Parenthood in the rest of these
eugenesis depression has some
upside and we look at the fact that you
know we know that these uh that these
anti-depressant drugs that everyone's
taking that that that you know they've
been prescribed under false pretenses of
curing a chemical imbalance that doesn't
exist and you see that and you see that
they're still being prescribed even
though they don't
work and you wonder why that's the
case well maybe for the powers that be
they're not supposed to work
you know and they also uh we know they
don't want anyone owning any property
back to the Jeff emo says quote housing
policies discouragement of private home
ownership that's a version of the wef's
line about how you'll own nothing and be
happy and plant Parenthood wrote it all
the way back in
1969 then there's the last column quote
payments to encourage sterilization
payments to encourage contraception
payments to encourage abortion abortion
and sterilization on demand allow
certain contraceptives to be distributed
non-medically improve contraception
technology make contraception truly
available and accessible to all well
again mission accomplished with Planned
Parenthood leading the charge so-called
gender affirming care quote unquote is
now available on demand in much of the
country children could take hormones
that will sterilize them for
Life meanwhile major corporations are
paying employees to fly out of state to
murder their
children now of course not everything in
the Jeff memo has come true compulsory
abortion for example uh is not yet the
law of the land we're not forcing people
to commit murder at least not yet but
that may be coming sooner than you think
consider the fact that euth in Asia
known as maid or medical assistance in
dying is now the sixth leading cause of
death in Canada and Maid does not
require a terminal diagnosis in Canada
in fact Canada's government is killing
some people simply because they're
disabled or mentally ill or can't find
housing they're even planning to open
made up to so-called mature minors
Nationwide and disabled people in Canada
are openly talking about this they're
talking about the fact that the
government is eager to kill
them watch if you call the number on the
government website they will provide
doctors that will sign off for you like
many disabled Canadians she is stuck in
a cycle of poverty and despair
it's no hope for anybody in Ontario
that's a good boy so she's planning to
end her life up with the government's
help they could have me dead in 90 days
that's what I was told like in my case
the problem is not really the disability
it is the poverty Les Landry is in the
same position wanting to live but seeing
no other option then death these two are
for my asthma this is for my COPD since
when did we stop looking at the value of
human life in this country it's a
question people with disabilities and
their Advocates ask
constantly so fullon uh dystopian future
has been achieved in Canada and it's
heading here as well and what is
Canada's government doing about this are
they trying to reverse course are they
trying to find a way to help these
people
live just the opposite actually just
this week statistics Canada which is the
agency in Canada's government that
cataloges how people are dying in Canada
um announced on social media that it's
effectively going to start hiding the
statistics on maid and here's what they
wrote about their recordkeeping
practices going forward quote the
underlying cause of death is defined as
the disease or injury that initiated the
train of morbid events leading directly
to death as such made deaths are coded
to the underlying condition for which
made was requested in response to that
post one Canadian asked for some
clarification he wrote quote how do you
classify people with a disability that
do not have a foreseeable death or
people that CHS made because of mental
health issues and here's how the agency
responded to that quote deaths are coded
using the World Health organization's
International classification of disease
and related health problems in the case
of a disability deaths are coded to the
underlying disability or mental health
issue that maid was granted for so in
other words if somebody is depressed and
the Canadian government puts them down
like dogs Canada will record that as a
death due to depression not euthanasia
or
suicide now if it doesn't seem like
something something like this could ever
happen here you should know that already
efforts are underway to bring maid to
the United States in November at a
meeting of the American Medical
Association a resolution was proposed to
remove this line from the association's
guidelines quote Physicians must not
perform euthanasia or perform assisted
suicide and instead of that line members
of the AMA proposed this revision quote
resolved that our American Medical
Association adopt a neutral stance on
Medical Aid and dying and respect the
autonomy and right of self-determination
of patients and physicians in this
matter so at this rate it's only a
matter of time before we adopt Canada's
made program Wholesale in this country
it's only a matter of time until we have
a marriage tax just like the ones
Frederick jaff was writing about with
every passing year we get closer and
closer to realizing every single wish
list item on the jaff memo we've seen
this agenda unfold in front of our eyes
for decades it's right there in front of
us it's not happening
naturally it's not
inevitable it was pre-planned
and even now it's still in
progress and when you realize that it
puts the fake debates over climate
change and quote unquote gender
affirment care in
context whatever branding they come up
with the end goal is and has always been
the same depopulation it is an
anti-human agenda
and that is where all this activism
leads you could choose to believe that
it's a coincidence you could come up
with some alternative theory for why
every single left-wing cause happens to
match perfectly with the jaff memo and
with the people that outlined their plan
to depopulate the planet but whatever
the case there's one thing you can't
deny which is that all the way back in
1969 Planned Parenthood planned all of
this
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there